i'm sexy and i know
i'm successful
[Music]
hi there i'm veronica cheggy and i'm sam
claflin
[Music]
hernandez movie
and today we're going to be taking a
quiz to determine which
characters we really are how would your
closest friends describe you charming
fun-loving logical old-fashioned
probably logical los
very charming so how do you like to
spend your friday nights with my family
on a date hitting the clubs or reading
with my family with my family definitely
reading so fun loving so i'd say you're
on a date or hitting the club though
okay now on a date on a date
what do you think is your best quality
i'm fabulous i'm reliable i'm sexy i put
others first reliable
honest relations
is fast i'm sexy and i know
what is your
weakness i get more easily i'm impatient
i have high standards i can be uptight
[Music]
high standards pick some mexican food to
eat
quesadillas enchiladas
once ghosted twice shy if i only had a
duke a night to surrender to love and to
load i think to love and to loathe have
you read that no i love to love and i
love to love you and i to surrender by
this day
[Music]
a night to surrender finally pick an
emoji so there's a heart with an arrow
through it a massive massive aubergine a
high heel just one though and the face
oh my god it's so clear to me the
aubergine
[Laughter]
because one day we talked about hiv yeah
we talked about how much you want to
wear
no i don't want to wear high heels i
wore them as a kid
i think every boy's tried them yeah i
think every man so that was my face that
was literally my face a second ago i
think this probably no when i tell your
face it's like
you wish
[Music]
[Laughter]
generous with others and brutally honest
yeah you can be skeptical when it comes
to love
and sometimes have a hard time trusting
others
that's a lie but you're looking for
fireworks in a relationship and once you
find the right person you'll give them a
real
rough
go and check our film
book of love
i can't say for you i'm the translator
of your book
why are all these people here i made
some changes
what have you done to my book
oh my lord i know
[Music]
you